a police chief is arrested and charged
while on vacation after he allegedly
attacked another man beat him up and
claimed he may have committed murder I
think a murder at night okay the
aftermath all caught on body camera
video as Key West Florida police
officers respond to a 9-1-1 call on July
28th at about one o'clock that morning a
taxi driver called the emergency line
reporting a man was banging on his
vehicle demanding 9-1-1 be contacted the
man later identified as 40-year-old Chad
McArdle claimed he had been stabbed by a
group of people officials later
confirmed McArdle is the police chief in
Boston Heights Ohio
[Music]
find
golf whatever sir
three guys
all right thank you you're the best in
the face too
right here he hit me puppy three or four
times
and then he got me right here so yeah
thanks man
so what item
do you have any idea who it is right
you're in Spanish so you said you were
in a car with them right they pulled me
in the car
body camera video captures McArdle
telling officers he too is a cop before
explaining what he says happened
[Applause]
no dude seriously look at it
oh I believe you yeah so I was like I
don't know what your guys
okay they get uh
it seem like my girlfriend where did
they pick you up at uh whatever bar
that uh
dirtbags
dirtbags Dirty Harry's yeah yes
okay so basically there's something
finale it's sort of keeping the face and
so
okay but I'm I'm pretty sure I killed
one of them you think you killed one of
them yeah like I've like he started
kicking me right in the nose and
I was like dude I'm like whatever
whatever and where did you walk from
down down here and I started screaming
I'm like would you show me show me where
you were so just walk with him for a
second in the face too
he hit me probably three or four times
hard and then he got me right here so
hey good luck yeah thanks man as McArdle
speaks with police he describes being
attacked and retaliating by stabbing his
alleged attacker with a stick
so he's like you I want your girlfriend
I'm like whatever man
so you think you have some sand on your
face
like I cracked the stick I was like
stepping the heck and you just like I
know
what
[Music]
foreign
McArdle explains he's from Ohio visiting
Key West just for one night a little bit
more descriptive like where did this
happen where did they look like it's an
Alleyway like right on there I put a
like a test cam over he's like dude
pulling in one and he's like drove off
so I was like hey hey you guys whatever
so like whatever but there were two guys
if you had a white beard black
so it has a white beer yeah
gray like scalp
so
how's it what do you want what do you
guys want me to do so you need to live
down here no still here
on vacation yeah where are you staying
at uh Miami
we came in here for one night okay where
are you staying at down here uh Airbnb
yeah
so where's your girlfriend I have no
clue I can't because they kept trying my
phone so I can't I can't activate it
White
[Music]
so
yeah man uh I'm a cop too
after that McArdle again mentions his
role as a police officer and says the
man he injured may be dead
the chief of police where I work so
that's like Dude like this dude drug me
down the alleyway and sort of kicked me
to face I like broke a stick sort of
stab him and that
I don't know if it's dead or not so
I was aiming right for here
I'll tell you that that dude right there
he continues to describe what he claims
happened he like came up and came in the
face I was like all right let's go I
broke up in the ranch off and started
just stabbing so
if I I don't want dude to be dead but
don't around with me dude
like it's like a good so
meanwhile other officers approached the
alleyway where the fight allegedly
happened there they find a homeless man
who says someone attacked him need to
come out here
oh
what's your name
Joe did you hear any commotion going on
like a fight or something this broke out
yeah
you did
come out here for me so I can see you
I'm in the alley right behind 424
Southern and I'm out with a 77 that
stated there was a fight that just took
place here
you were hiding from him yeah so what
did you hear
I don't know the guy just
was it right here was it over here
it was well
I was standing right there you were here
okay and he kicked me in the back kicked
you yeah
I mean I don't know
if you could describe this guy what did
he look like
and not your size okay what was he
wearing
I don't know
but did you notice anything that you'd
be able to pick out okay
I would say uh blonde or redhead okay
skinny guy kind of bulky heavy set yeah
did you do anything to him when he
kicked you
know I hit the ground matter of fact my
back is
the man tells another officer the
suspect threatened to kill him okay and
you're over here when he attacked you
yeah it was going on there so when he
came up and attacked you did he say
anything
no he said I'm gonna kill you
very good
foreign
anything else
so
I'm just I'm trying to wrap my head
around everything to happen all right so
you were standing right here
where did the guy come from
because he kicked me in the back so were
you standing you're standing right here
okay so you're standing right here
turning around so your back was facing
to the alley
and he just walked up and kicked you
so you didn't see him coming is what
you're saying I didn't see him commented
and hearing
and when I hit the ground
[Music]
he kicked me a couple more times
okay
um
did you did you try to defend yourself
at any point
yeah you never try to defend yourself at
any point he was ways Beyond me okay
all right I'm not a fighter I understand
body camera video captures officers
discussing the exchange between McArdle
and the homeless man I can't get any
description of all these people so
you're stabbed multiple times there's
absolutely zero stabbings on them
whatsoever all we can collaborate is it
to beat this poor guy up in an alley for
no reason that's right
who wants to press charges after that
McArdle is taken into custody all right
turn off put your hands on your back
we're gonna Entertain You Right Now
another investigation
oh no it might be in charge or something
right now you are you are two things I
think I murdered at night okay Mercado
was arrested and charged with battery
right now he's on paid administrative
leave from the Boston Heights Police
Department reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie